est ce que je regrette c'est que le
gouvernement a considéré qu'il y avait
pas de question d'ailleurs on a entendu
la ministre aujourd'hui dire que y'avait
pas de problème éthique sur la pma et si
il ya un problème éthique
il ya un problème parce que faire naître
un enfant sans père ça pose quand même
un problème sur l'avenir cet enfant
parce que le premier ministre avant
qu'il soit premier ministre disait je
suis contre la pma parce qu'elle amènera
obligatoirement à la gpa et je pense
qu'il n'avait pas tort à l'époque un peu
changé d'avis depuis mais il est devenu
premier ministre
et puis vous le savez on a une pénurie
de gamètes et cette pénurie de gamètes
elle va entraîner obligatoirement ce qui
arrive dans tous les pays démocratiques
quand il ya une pénurie il ya une
marchandisation est ce que dans cinq ans
les mêmes diront pas finalement j'ai
réfléchi et je suis pour la gpa et vous
avez bien vu tout à l'heure qui a un
certain nombre de personnes qui met déjà
le débat sur le sujet précise pour le
téléspectateur vous parle pas tellement
de ses députés la république en marche
qui ont fait savoir il ya quelques
semaines il voudrait que dans la chaîne
sur nuit il dit parler de la gpa mais
parce que c'est lié
donc c'est des éléments qui sont pas
négligeables avec le fait en plus que la
médecine aujourd'hui elle est faite pour
soigner les pathologies et le fait pour
réparer les anomalies
elle n'est pas faite pour répondre au
désir d'enfant au désir en général je
trouve que la question a été beaucoup
éludé parce que ça a été un engagement
du président qui a dit on le fera il
avait pris la précaution de dire si
c'est consensuel
je constate que ça n'est pas vraiment
consensuelle et si vous lisez ce que dit
le rapport du comité d'éthique
il amène justement ces dangers y compris
les dangers de la marchandisation des
gamètes c'est le comité d'éthique qui le
dit mais que dans la république en
marche quand il ya une députée qui est
contre en exclu parce qu'elle n'a pas le
droit de penser autre chose que la
pensée unique
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne façon de rentrer dans le débat
éthique qui consiste à dire on n'est pas
dans une vérité révélée
on n'est pas dans une morale établie on
est dans une interrogation non pas entre
le bien et le mal les gentils et les
méchants
on est dans une interrogation dans un
conflit de valeurs et si on prend le
problème de l'égalité dans la
procréation
on dira pourquoi de femmes y auraient
droit et pourquoi deux hommes n'y aurait
pas droit
or on n'a pas droit à un être humain on
a droit des objets ou mais sinon c'est
un problème de liberté
la famille c'est libre la sexualité doit
être libre mais pour autant on n'a pas
droit à une personne humaine n'a pas
droit un enfant l'enfant a des droits
on n'a pas des droits mais la voix
aujourd'hui il ya des frais et que ces
frais doivent être tous justifiés vous
savez moi j'ai été ministre avec comme
tutelle alain juppé quant aux et yom
ministre fait européenne élue ministre
d'état et bien il y avait une règle
c'est que on payer les repas qui se
déroulait au quai d'orsay pour toutes
les personnes privées
c'est pas très compliqué non pas à le
dire parce que c'est comme ça qu'on le
sent mais à dire c'est obligatoire c'est
très compliqué à faire moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux aborder des règles très
strictes
plutôt que de temps en temps d'avoir une
victime expiatoire que l'on montre au
peuple en disant voyez celui-là il a
fauté et on va le plus